welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition and it's time to
turn it up to eleven as we head back to
the world of stranger things with season
three now on Netflix it's time to break
down everything that you need to know
about the show as well as what happens
in its ending there will be heavy
spoilers here so if you haven't had a
chance to watch stranger things through
yet and don't want anything ruined then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
put that away huge thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our breakdown of stranger things season
3 stranger things 3 picks up in 1985 two
years after the events of season two and
centers around our cast of characters
prepping for the 4th of July
celebrations and Hawkins Indiana from
the off it's very clear that though the
show is set over 30 years ago the events
that take place in it are a comment on
modern society with Russia trying to
bring down America from within by
unleashing a monster on the country in
case you hadn't guessed it this is one
big drum metaphor and there's a lot of
strong double meanings laced throughout
that showcase that season 3 has a far
more political side to it than its
predecessors Nancy and Jonathan now work
at a local newspaper and this too
becomes a comment on the me2 movement
and the rise of feminism due to the fact
that Nancy's ideas are always dismissed
and sexism runs rampant throughout the
office she's pretty much just the girl
who gets the coffee and throughout
season 3 she has to battle the closed
mindedness of her apparent male
superiors in order to unearth the truth
of the new inhabitants that seem to be
popping up it's not all bad though and
mike and xi or deepen their relationship
much to jim hoppers dismay he puts up a
couple of barriers in the way and it's
kind of hilarious how much he relishes
breaking them up but the rest of the
friendship group are already finding
partners and growing up his characters
bar will who seems to want things to
just stay the way they are he senses
that there's something wrong in the area
and as the characters grows so does the
dark presence in the town this carries
over to the entire plot of the season
and this coming-of-age story really
flashes out the characters far beyond
what we've seen so far it definitely
does more work for character building
than the prior two seasons in my
piñon and for me this was the most
relatable I've ever seen the group
however the shadow in the sky still
looms and no amount of ice cream from
scoops of hi is gonna stop it belly is
pulled to the upside-down and during
this he comes face to face with a shadow
version of himself and returns with the
dark side and a need to feed the beast
that has begun to inhabit the town in
addition to this Dustin intercepts a
Russian transmission and with help from
Steve and Robin they discover the truth
behind the invasion all of the plots
beautifully interweave with one another
and now each character discovers certain
things on their own it comes together
perfectly to create a cohesive narrative
that's arguably the tightest in the
Netflix show so far eventually the group
come face to face with the mine player
and dark presence that has been growing
in the town doctor Alexi reveals that
the Russians have been building a
doorway between the worlds and that they
need to operate their machine in Hawkins
as the door has already been open there
and is still accessible xi learns
through visiting billy in a vision that
there's a source of the entire invasion
that is tied to the emotional trauma
that he has over his parents divorce and
half-sister Maxine this leads the group
to learn about the steelworks where
Billy had been bringing people but the
plan backfires and alerts those infected
to 11 and the other's presence she
discovers that those from the upside
down have been building everything to
take down 11 and the rest of the world
and are finally ready to attack now that
the mine player knows exactly where 11
is he heads there faster than I clicked
on stranger things when I saw there were
new episodes and finally we see the big
faceoff that we've been waiting for it
leads to an awesome last couple of
episodes that gave me Resident Evil 2
flashbacks and my heart was really
racing as we got into the finale at Star
Court mall all of the characters joined
together and it's at this point that the
season really comes into its own with
some of the group facing down against
Billy and the mine player some head to
Dustin's Ariel and others descend into
the basement to stop the Russian weapon
from going all she Noble on the scene in
this never ending story though they
manage to close the doorway and the kids
show that fireworks against the mind
flayer by using well fireworks against
the mind flayer that doesn't mean it's a
happy ending Billy sacrifices himself
and Jim apparently dies in order to shut
down the seal season 3 ends with 11
reading an old letter
written by Jim and she joins Joyce will
and Jonathan as they move out of Hawkins
and go on to a new life
however it's not over yet and we then
cut to a post-credits scene which takes
place and come chapter I think I've
pronounced out right where prisoners are
being fed to a returning evil that comes
in the form of the demagogue in prison
guards linger in front of a door before
one of them says no not the American and
then they drag another captive to his
death so to me there's two big returns
here not just the demagoguing but also
Jim hopper who I believe was found when
the Russians inspected the weapon at the
end hopper is now being held hostage and
this will be revealed in season four Jim
will bring the demagogue in back into
the limelight and the return of stranger
things will center around the characters
trying to not only rescue him but also
stop the new evil that's rising in
Russia whether this happens or not we
will see but I definitely think it's the
way that season fall will be heading
with the group getting back together
with one another to save Jim but what
did I think of the season as a whole
well I don't know if I'm gonna catch
some flack for this but I actually
thought that this is the best season so
far it beautifully balances the 80s
nostalgia and references that tie into
the story in a way that doesn't feel too
heavy-handed and far more natural and
the prior two seasons the drama is
heightened expertly and the political
aspect of the show doesn't feel too
forced and it allows it to be enjoyed on
a surface level each character really
gets a moment to shine here and it ends
with stakes that feel impactful I loved
all of the new characters and they feel
like incredible additions to the
narrative that makes the cast some of
the best television cohorts we currently
have overall season three was incredible
and it gets a nine out of ten so yeah
great show happy Independence Day to all
the American viewers I'm not better I'm
not better about it I'm not better about
you country live in the UK but thanks
anyway obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on stranger things season 3 did
you enjoy it and what would you like to
see in season 4 comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out our breakdown of Midsomer which
you'll be linked at the end I give my
thoughts on the brand new horror movie
and discuss all of the symbolism in it
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you
more about the film I leave that linked
at the end and hopefully I'll see you
over there Cheers
this is a channel for people who are
never missing television so if that's
the kind of thing you like you need to
subscribe to definition thanks again for
taking the time to watch this you've
been the best and I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]